aber ghana
löw meine lieben frauen und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft command heute am mittwoch
ja weil ich gestern am dienstag nicht
geschafft habe und zwar stelle ich euch
heute wieder einen kurzen kleinen co
großen kunden bedeckt hallo
die eventuell seht daran dass sich ein
bisschen sonnenbrand habe oder er holt
aussehe oder ich bin richtig heiß auf ok
in der tat und zwar komme ich aus dem
urlaub ich bin gestern abend wieder
gekommen und für montag hatte ich
eigentlich gedacht ein video aus dem
urlaub hochzuladen so wo ich fragen
beantworte
das hat allerdings nicht geklappt weil
das internet dort richtig scheiße war
und die zweite sache die ich noch sagen
wollte am dienstag also gestern sollte
eigentlich dieses video hier kommen das
nehme ich jetzt allerdings heute am
dienstagabend auffällig wie gesagt erst
um 21 uhr zu hause habe ich auch im bild
bei instagram kostet interessiert euch
wahrscheinlich alles gar nicht deswegen
kommt heute auf jeden fall die minecraft
commands folge mit einem umfangreicheren
command wie ich das gesagt hatte dass
jetzt jeden dienstag mal mache und dann
hab ich mir gedacht dann gestern und
vorgestern keine videos kann mache ich
heute abend nochmal runde wo ich einfach
so ein paar fragen beantworte ganzjährig
jedenfalls wurde mir wieder einige
command zugesendet also einfach sagte
hey es gibt jemanden der halt so und so
der hat den und dem command vor
geschäftsstelle mal vor
das sind über ganz nett wenn das relativ
kurzen die kommentare bei mir
geschrieben wird zu hey was ist denn mit
dem mit dem command youtube suche
einfach mal blass das und das und da hat
mir jemand gesagt hey es gibt einen
world edit command & world ist ja
eventuell eventuell kennst du ein oder
andere wenn der ein oder andere nicht
das ist etwas womit man einfacher
strukturen in minecraft generieren kann
also ihr kennt wahrscheinlich von ihnen
welchen servern oder von welchen welt
nämlich runterladen wenn die hochhäuser
sind oder so denkt man sich so wie
dieses ding ist von blogger hof wie
könnt ihr dann jeden jedes einzelne jede
einzelne jedes einzelne stück weg bauen
und so was alles redet ja eigentlich das
geht ganz einfach über world und zwar
kann man dann quasi einfach ein
stockwerk bauen und das quasi wird dann
dauerhaft kopiert und geht dann immer
wieder weiter nach oben und so ein
command wurde minecraft hinzugefügt wir
hatten das ja schon mal dass ich euch
beispielsweise den links gezeigt hatte
den
so was wie ich sag mal wie blogs oder
sowas eigentlich eine mod ist und wer
ist eigentlich auch so eine art sage ich
jetzt mal und zwar ist es von google 014
findet seinen namen link dazu alles in
der beschreibung weil es ein command ist
natürlich klar
am besten einfach mal vorbeischauen
vielleicht eine schöne booster lassen
video ist auch eine beschreibung
verlinkt er hat das in vier minuten
erklärt ich bin jetzt schon fast über
vier minuten
wir sehen da bleibt doch schon der
letzte command blog rein und wir haben
hier eine maschine wo wir einerseits 42
command blogs haben 82 wolle blöcke und
hier noch ein kompakt einen wolle blog
luca einen wolle block und dann sehen
wir hier schon die schilder world edit
bei 314 click to destroy das machen wir
natürlich nicht und click to enable
world and click to disable world editors
kann man ganz einfach disable wir haben
ziemlich grad disabled allerdings das
zeige ich euch mal ganz einfach daran
wenn ich beispielsweise einen tnt in die
hand nehme und das einfach mal hier
nehmen das schaf zum beispielsweise ich
das tempo anziehe seht ihr schon
wir haben es disabled weil das tnt ganz
normal schaden kreiert wenn ich jetzt
allerdings mal auf click to enable world
ticket schon ich bekomme drei andere
items ins inventar wird sich das kreiert
dazu komme ich gleich allerdings am
besten zeige ich euch das mal am tnt
beispiel und bücher hier vorhinein tnt
habe explodieren lassen wenn ich jetzt
ein tnt dahin setzen das jetzt
explodieren lassen
ja und zwar ist es quasi world in
abgespeckter version wenn ich jetzt das
krass ist es einfach wenn ich fange es
mal mit dem thema tnt wenn ich disabled
habt ihr gesehen es hat hier diese
dieses loch gemacht wenn ich wollte
tanner bild habe am mache ich hier
generiert das tmd quasi das grab bzw
das was kaputt gemacht hat das ganze
kann man
hier ganz easy ändern und zwar kann ich
den blog kaputt schlagen hier und ich
greife hier drauf zu ich wusste das ist
der falsche command block war ich meine
wolle blog luca ich meine rolle block
und zwar dass dieser hier dieser obere
wenn ich darauf zugreifen seht ihr schon
hier steht gras groß wenn ich hier ist
beispielsweise mal wohin schreiben würde
so fertig und ich würde jetzt rein
theoretisch mal hier ein
tnt hinsetzen und das ganz einfach
anzünden würdet ihr jetzt schon sehen
dass dort kein gras wieder generiert
wird sondern dementsprechend jetzt wolle
oder dann dann kann ich da
beispielsweise auch mal hin schreiben
anstatt wolle weil sie nicht was kann
ich da hin schreiben schreibt mal so
wenn jetzt antennen schreibe und hier
oben beispielsweise noch einen drauf
setzte das jetzt ganz dieses mal
anzusehen wenn dieses ding gleich
explodiert wird dort keine wolle raus
kommt auf keinen klar gras sondern sand
und der verletzten den seiten runter
also das ist quasi inverted tnt also
umgekehrtes tnt heißt es dass es eine
funktion hinzugefügt wurde und wenn ich
wieder auf dieselbe klick ist halt
wieder vorbei das ist nur eine sache von
den ganzen sachen eventuell habe ich das
auch schon zu lange drüber geredet
ich mache mir die unnötige sachen weg
und zwar zu supermarkt und super für
komme ich gleich allerdings jetzt erst
mal zum reiss leiten was wir gerade
schon hier gesehen haben ihr seht
nämlich schon nicht laufe ganz einfach
geradeaus und eigentlichen unter mir
keine blöcke allerdings ich hab mir grad
quasi eine kleine treppe dort kreiert
wenn ich nämlich dieses item in der hand
habe und beispielsweise einfach mal hoch
fliege oder so nicht funktioniert das
nicht
dann geht ihr schon dass das quasi reis
und laura also es wird hochgezogen die
welt hinter einem und es wird kleiner
gemacht das heißt wenn ich
beispielsweise so bin ich hier
wenn ich shift gedrückt haltet mich
einfach mal drauf stelle beispielsweise
das alte männer hand und ich halte
schiff gedrückt dann sollte eigentlich
ja genau jetzt sehen wir schon da geht
an die welt wieder runter so ein
bisschen
da kann ich das ganze quasi damit tiefer
machen und ich sage mal ja ein bisschen
bis ins erdreich bis in die höhle mit
reingehen das liegt alles ein bisschen
weil ich schon das ganze wasser muss
jetzt beispielsweise mit runter und
jetzt fliege ich beispielsweise wieder
hoch und jetzt kann ich das wieder
hochziehen hier das dauert jetzt wieder
ein bisschen da haben was und desto mehr
ich bin desto höher wird das aufgezogen
das heißt da vorne ist es noch so hoch
und wenn ich jetzt auf dieser stelle bin
ist schon so hoch und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal so hoch liege seht
ihr schon gleich kommt dass hier schon
so hoch gehandelt und dann sehen wir
schon habe ich jeden moment auch hier
einen berg kreiert falls ich das denn
man möchte er das noch hier irgendwann
mal machen oder
ok neues möchte einfach nicht trotzdem
etwas richtig cooles kreiert warte ich
mal ganz kurz hier eine fackel in der
hand
dann kann ich euch das für mich so ein
bisschen besser mal zeigen hier schaue
ich das mal anders sie haben das haben
wir gerade einfach kreiert und unserer
sache das waren quasi wir hier war keine
höhle oder war jedoch eine hülle
doch es kann schon sein dass jedoch eine
hülle war allerdings dass hier wo das
hier hoch geht das hier waren alles wir
jetzt mit unserem world editing das seht
ihr schon das haben wir hier quasi
einfach hochgezogen das ist richtig und
das kann man mit diesem race lauer alter
machen dann haben wir hier noch super
viel und supermarkt darauf werde ich
jetzt nur kurz eingehen weil das video
mir schon wieder viel zu lange ist wenn
ich heute zwei videos mache das besser
als überhaupt hinkriegen mit dem
schneiden und so und zwar nehme ich mir
dafür nicht mal einfach mal hier nehme
ich mir so einen schwarzen dingen und
dann nehme ich mir noch von pulse wollte
an diesem scheiß pilz aber das sollte
eigentlich reichen das ist eine fackel
ich hab das schwarz eichenholz sondern
hole ich mir jetzt beispielsweise hier
noch das birkenholz so und wenn ich
jetzt einfach mal rein theoretisch mir
denke ja ich stelle hier einfach mal
eine wand hin beispielsweise hier dann
mache ich hier und dazwischen kommt eine
fackel
ich weiß nicht inwiefern ist mit fackeln
klappt oder mit bilderrahmen oder
irgendwie sowas was man halt aufhängen
kann das können jetzt aber einfach mal
live testen und zwar nehme ich mir dass
beispielsweise ich einfach mal nein ich
hatte ganz großartig vollidiot aber
eigentlich ist ganz nah ich meine ich
habe jetzt ganz so eine fläche kreiert
baue ich hier einfach mal normal dass
hin so etwas in jedem fall etwas hin und
da eine fackel und da eine fackel
beispielsweise da nehme ich mir diese
mainz dauern und nicht dass er aufs gras
altem wechselt und jetzt setze ich sage
ich mal hier oben
einen super viel hin und dann setze ich
hier unten einen supermarkt hin und
jetzt seht ihr schon wie ihr seht ihr
nix eventuell habe ich vertauscht war
die letzten male ein super film und hier
oben ein supermarkt ihr thema schon und
zwar werden dann diese teile hier
kreiert diese komischen lila dinge die
darunter fallen und alle sachen die sich
jetzt dazwischen befinden werden quasi
hochgezogen das problem ist gerade das
der die sachen aus dem untergrund hoch
wie ihr seht schon da unten das muss das
genau welche muster wieder oben und
nicht meine komische wand okay ich baue
ich hier eine konstruktion sage ich mal
die hier jetzt nehme ich mir
beispielsweise einen sand block und
setzt sich unten einen supermarkt hin
und jetzt beispielsweise hier oben einen
super
dann müsste rein theoretisch das ganze
hochgezogen werden oder vertue ich mich
gerade irgendwie des todes ich meine da
ist der supermarkt hier ist super
jetzt haben wir jetzt wie das hier schon
wieder a
nee ich verstehe es gab diese funktion
ist denn gerade alles nicht jetzt sieht
das irgendwie so komische sachen nach
oben eventuell dax auch einfach daran
dass ich gerade wieder dieses komische
highlighter mir nach dass ich diese
seite im grab einer hand hatte es tut
mir leid dass ich das gar nicht richtig
zeigen kann bei mir hat es folien
perfekt funktioniert und zwar ist es
einfach so wenn ich beispielsweise und
seine band hinstelle dass ich dann unten
ein super film habla keine ahnung gerade
weil es gerade ihn nicht funktioniert
und oben einen anderen rüstung ständer
von den beiden und danach liegt das
quasi die ganze zeit abgeglichen das
heißt die kindlich fallen immer diese
brötchen darunter das wasserrad
unterfallen seht und es wird quasi immer
wieder gecheckt ob etwas neues gebaut
wurde wenn man was neues potter wird das
andere dementsprechend dementsprechend
dementsprechend verändern das sollte
doch eigentlich schon mal dieser
commands vorstellung jetzt gewesen sein
ich versuche gerade dieses ding immer
höher zu ziehen dieses blaue race alte
mir weil damit hab ich irgendwie meisten
spaß würde ich dir diese dinger jessica
naja um
jetzt generiert sich hier gerade fragt
sieht er richtig crazy aus ja das war es
mit dieser command vorstellung
ich konnte alles zeigen dass auch dieses
fiel und marca wenn jeder biss wie genau
funktioniert ihr findet einen link in
der beschreibung oder einfach in die
kommentare
egal tschüss hier sehen uns heute abend
in fragen wie du wiederkommst baghdadi
total rom und hier ist auch schon diese
komischen lila überall verteilt hier
vorne
wir sehen seit anderen fragen video
wieder und ich hoffe dass wir da wieder
einschaltet wenn es euch gefallen habe
ich mich über eine bewertung freuen und
wir sehen uns irgendwann wieder